This is the beginning of volume four. The year is 1900, and we begin in September the 5th, 1900.
And the first message is how hope and love help each other. So just as a reminder,
the three theological virtues are faith, hope, and love. And the greatest of these is love.
That's 1 Corinthians 13, 13. And 1 Corinthians 14, 1 says you must want love more than anything else.
This is September the 5th, 1900. Hope is the nourishment of love.
So for hope, I want to give you Isaiah 40, 31. Those who wait or hope in the Lord shall renew their
strength. They shall rise up with wings like the eagle. They shall run and not be weary. They shall
walk and not faint. Since in the past days, Louisa said, "By adorable Jesus had not made himself
seen so much." I was feeling different about the hope of re-acquiring him again. Even more,
I believed that everything was over for me. The visits from our Lord and the state of victim soul.
However, this morning, blessed Jesus came wearing a horrible crown of thorns and placed himself near
me, moaning in the act of wanting a refreshment. A refreshment, of course, means doing something to
save souls. So I removed the crown very gently, Louisa said, and in order to give him more pleasure,
I put it on my head. She's nothing if she isn't very courageous. I mean, which of us would do that?
Then he said to me, "My daughter, true love is when it is sustained by hope
and by persevering hope." And of course, hope is what sustains you in his absence. So it is
absolutely essential for us. Because if today, I hope for tomorrow and tomorrow, I do not,
love becomes infirm. In fact, since love is nourished by hope, the more nourishment it
administers to it, the stronger the more robust and the more lively love becomes. And if this is
missing, poor love becomes infirm first, and remaining all alone without support, it ends up
dying completely. So hope keeps love alive. Therefore, as long as you're as great as your
difficulties may be, you must never, even for one instant, move away from hope with the fear
of losing me. On the contrary, you must act. Now notice the act in such a way that overcoming
everything, that means all her feelings, all her doubts, all her sorrows, everything. And for
overcoming, I want to give you a revelation two and three for all the messages about the
overcomers throughout those passages. So I want you to act in such a way, Jesus said,
that overcoming everything hope may make you be found always united with me. And then love will
have perennial life. In other words, love will be able to flourish. So after this, he continued
coming without telling me anything else, Louisa said. So September the sixth 1900, here we talk
about the state of victim soul. My most sweet Jesus continues to come. This morning, as soon as he
came, he wanted to pour a little bit of his bitterness into me. And then he told me, my daughter,
I want to sleep a little bit. Now Jesus sleeping in the boat is very important. And that's Mark
chapter four, verses 35 to 41. I want you to sleep a little. I want to sleep a little, he said,
and I want you to do my office of suffering. That's the office of Redeemer, or in her case,
core redeemer, praying and placating justice. So there you have Louisa's role as a victim soul to
suffer, to pray and to placate divine justice. So he fell asleep and I began to pray near Jesus.
Now that image of Jesus sleep in the boat has the apostles working and Jesus sleeping. And that's
what you have here, Louisa working and Jesus resting. Later as he woke up, we went around a
little in the midst of people. And he showed me several conspiracies that were that are making
in order to provoke a revolution. Well, that's obviously communist Marxism, because it was
breaking upon the world in the year 1900. Especially I noticed a sudden assault they were plotting,
so as to better achieve their intent. And so, so that no one might be able to defend or guard
himself against the enemy. How many gloomy scenes Louisa said. However, it seems that the Lord is
not yet giving them the freedom to do this. They didn't succeed until 1917 in the Bolshevik
revolution in Russia. And not knowing the reason they were consumed with rage, because in spite of
their perverse will, they see themselves powerless to do it, to actually carry it out. Now they don't
know John 15 5. Jesus says without me, you can do nothing. We know from the higher volumes that
Jesus tells us that if the divine will is operating within us, the divine will has to consent to
whatever it allows us to do. And here we're being told that the divine will is not consenting to
this evil right now. It's not the right time people have to be given more time to get their their act
together. Now notice their perverse will. So in we're going to be dealing with a good deal of
chastisements and that in the coming pieces that we read. And and I just want to remind you of the
human will against the divine will. And that is the reason for the chastisement that we're absolutely
opposing what God wants to do in us through us and all the rest of it. So, Louisa continues,
it takes nothing else but the Lord to concede this freedom to them for everything is ready.
They're ready to do their evil. God is not ready to let them do it. Now, if you go back to the book
of Exodus, you find that the the children of Jacob who eventually became the nation of Israel,
that they had been 400 years in slavery. But God waited until Moses was ready. And so Moses had
to do 40 years in the wilderness. And when Moses was ready, the people were ready because they had
learned to stop complaining and to start praying and repenting. So when Moses was ready, the people
were ready. And then God said, yes, it's time for the Exodus. So here, one of the elements is not
in place. And that is the people are obviously still doing good.
So after this, we came back, Louisa said from or out of the body experience. And Jesus showed
himself all wounded and said to me, see how many wounds they have opened in me and the necessity
of the continuous state of victim. He's trying to get Louisa to look at the fact that her victim
state has got to be continuous. She's got to stop this business of saying, oh, maybe I shouldn't be
here. Maybe I should go out and all the rest of it. He's saying, no, it must be continuous.
Because she has no idea that they have just entered into the cruelest and the most evil and the most
violent of all centuries of history, which is the 20th century. And therefore, the victim soul is
more necessary than normal. So you must see the necessity of the continuous state of victim of
your sufferings, because there's not a moment in which they spare me offenses. Now, just as a
reminder, because we're going into a new volume, you have to remember the vision of Pope Leo XIII
before the 19th century, in which he witnessed a conversation between Satan and Jesus. And Satan
asked Jesus to give him a hundred years and he would destroy the church. And amazingly, Jesus
said, yes. Why would he say yes? Because it was time for the sifting of the church. Now, you remember
just before the passion that Jesus said to the apostles that Satan would sift them like wheat.
That was in the terrible crisis of the passion. So in the terrible crisis of the 20th century,
the church was going to be sifted like wheat. And like the apostles would show how much she
would fail the Lord, unfortunately, and we're not out of that crisis yet, a century later.
But of course, centuries are only moments in eternal space. So Jesus said to her
that since the offenses are continuous, the sufferings and the prayers must also be continuous.
So that I may be spared, he says, that's very interesting now. He doesn't say that the people
may be spared. And if you see that your suffering is suspended, tremble with fear, because not seeing
myself relieved of my pains, may it not be that I concede to the enemies, the freedom so yearned
for by them. Now here's Louisa really being ticked off. And she's being told that if you don't do
this office of victim soul, these people will succeed in what they're doing. And I may even give
them permission. Okay. Now notice, he said, I am suffering. Now, since Jesus is in glory,
since the resurrection, how is he suffering? He's suffering in his body, the church. That's number
one. And not only that, but throughout these writings, Jesus says that he is the head of the
human race and that when he became incarnate, he enclosed all souls within himself so that he could
redo all lives. And therefore, he is suffering for everyone, because he is divine. And we are the
branches, john 15. So Louisa said on hearing this, I began to pray that he would let me suffer. And
in the meantime, I saw the confessor who with his intentions pressed Jesus to make me suffer. So
there's you have the Trinity on earth, the priest, the victim and Jesus. And once that Trinity all
says, yes, it'll happen. Then blessed Jesus shared with me so many pains that I myself don't know how
I remained alive. However, the Lord did not leave me alone in my pains on the contrary, it seemed
that he did not have the heart to leave me. Now in these early volumes, because we're only still
on the foundational volume four, and the foundations are volumes one to four, and then you start building
from five to 10, and then you get the roof in volumes 11 and 12. So we're still on foundations.
And Louisa begins to realize that if she is suffering to the point of almost death,
that the Lord will not leave her alone at all. Now, why is that? It's because she is not living
a normal life. She's sitting in a bed. She's nothing to sustain her. She's nothing to build body,
soul or spirit. Only the Lord can miraculously sustain her. And so when she's going through this
terrible trauma of suffering like this, he stays with her. And of course, in later volumes, she's
going to moan that he doesn't come like that anymore. That's because circumstances will have
changed. And her vocation will have shifted from victim soul to being the foundation person
for the kingdom of the divine will. So she said, I spent several days together with Jesus and he
communicated many graces to me and made me understand many things. However, partly because of the
suffering state and because I am unable to express myself, I'll move on. Now in the higher volumes,
she won't be allowed to do that. She must actually say it all. And sometimes even in the early volumes,
the Lord absolutely insists on her coming back on a subject and giving it in greater detail.
So September 9, 1900, Jesus prepares Louisa for Holy Communion and the necessity of shedding blood.
So Jesus continues to come, Louisa said, however, I spent most of the night without Jesus. Then
oncoming, he told me, my daughter, what do you want that you are so anxiously waiting for me?
Do you perhaps need anything? You see, he is miraculously sustaining her. So he will ask this.
And Louisa said, since I knew I was to receive Holy Communion, I said, Lord, I waited for you
the whole night, more so because having to receive Communion, in those days you see, people didn't
receive every day. That only came into focus after Vatican Council. So having to receive Communion,
I fear that my heart may not be well disposed to be able to receive you. Therefore, I need that
my soul be reviewed by you so that it may be disposed to unite me with you sacramentally.
Now, one of the areas of real challenge for the rest of us is how much preparation Louisa wanted
to put into receiving Holy Communion. She obviously had an understanding of the immaculate holiness
and purity of God that we have lost today. And Jesus kindly reviewed my soul to prepare me to
receive him. Then he transported me outside of myself and I found myself together with the queen
mother who was saying to Jesus, my son, this soul will always be ready to do and to suffer
whatever we want. Now, notice that we, because blessed mother and Jesus were the only ones who
lived the divine will for the whole of their lives. And therefore, she is completely and totally
part of the divine will in heaven as well. And this is a bond that binds our justice. Now, notice
our justice. In the higher volumes, Louisa had an experience of being taken into heaven and she
saw the saints and she saw the angels and she said, but where is our mother? I don't see her.
And Jesus had to take her into a very deep place and she said she had to go very deep
into the blessed Trinity to even see the blessed mother. And that's why she said the blessed mother
was the height of sanctity or we would say the summer. So you see that she's identified with the
divine will. Therefore, blessed mother said, spare so many slaughters and so much blood,
which is to be shed among the people. But Jesus said, my mother, the shedding of blood is necessary
because I want this line of kings deposed from its throne. Now, it's 1900 and we're preparing
for the Bolshevik Revolution. So obviously you're talking about the Tsar of Russia. But we know in
I think it's in volume four that the king of Italy was also disposed of. And so that monarchy
disappeared as well. I want this line of kings deposed from its throne. And this cannot be without
blood. And this is also to purge my church, which is very much infected. Now, we know that they
the royal house in Russia was infected by all kinds of heresies at the time of its destruction.
And so the Lord wants to get rid of that. So I want you to put Revelation 11. I think it's 18.
I will destroy the destroyers of the earth because you see the the royal household had far too
much influence over the whole nation. And this will also purge my church, which is very much
infected. At the most I can concede to spare them in part. Now, we'll discover as we go along in part
means one third. That's incredible power to give to one human being. And if you remember the
intercession of Abraham in Genesis 18, then you'll realize, Genesis only, sorry, not Genesis, Abraham
only got lot and his family. Louisa gets one third of the whole place that's being interceded for.
In this case, I think it's Russia. I could be wrong, but that's what I think. But to be spared one
third just because one person is praying is absolutely incredible. So in the meantime,
Louisa said, I saw the majority of the deputies plotting on how to make the king fall. Now because
she uses the term king, it also seems to include the king of Italy. And so she sees the deputies
in parliament plotting to destroy him. And they do actually succeed in killing the king of Italy.
And they do, the Marxist do succeed in killing the Romanov family as well.
So the majority of the deputies were plotting how to make the king fall. And they were thinking
of putting on the throne one of those deputies who were assembled. Now, no monarchy ever
arose initially after the death of the king. After this, I found myself inside
of myself. Oh, how many miseries she said. Our Lord have compassion on the blindness of poor
humanity. Now, of course, she's looking at the future. So that's Isaiah 4610 and Amos 3 7. The
Lord tells the prophets before he does anything. So Louisa continues then continuing to see the
Lord and the queen mother. I saw the confessor with them and the most holy virgin said, see my son.
We have a third party, the confessor, who wants to unite with us to offer this work by committing
himself in order to concur, in order to make her suffer. Now, this is actually very important.
The confessor is Father Genaro di Genaro. And he entered more and more deeply into this,
although only one of the confessor was canonized. And that was Hannibal de Francea.
Okay, so he's committing himself. I just want to underline that. That's actually very important.
To concur in order to make her suffer to satisfy divine justice. This too is like rendering the
rope stronger, which binds you in order to placate you. Besides, when have you ever resisted the
strength of the unions of the one who suffers and prays? Now, what the blessed mother is talking
about here is that the power of victim souls, because victim souls are not like us, they don't
just say words, they actually pay a price for what they're asking for. Okay. So when have you you
ever opposed the unions of the one who suffered? So I also want to give you Matthew 1819,
where two of you gather together in my name, I am there, and when two of you pray, it's ratified
in heaven, hence the word unions in the plural, because Louisa wasn't the only victim soul.
There was thrays new man, there was Padre Pio, there was Alex Andrina, there was Martha Roba,
and a whole lot of others in the 20th century as well. And that's just Europe as not talking
about the rest of the world. And when have you ever resisted one who concurs with you for the
sole purpose of glorifying you and for the good of the peoples? Now the one who's concurring with
him is the priest in the name of the church. So Jesus was listening to his mother, he had regard
for the confessor, that's the one she was talking about. But he did not pronounce a sentence completely
favorable, rather he limited himself to spare in part. Now Louisa seems to think that he should
spare everything. So we continue in September the 10th with more threats against the perverted world.
Now it's called the perverted world because it's the human will rebelling against the divine will.
The entire Bible, particularly the Old Testament, that is a summary of it, that the human will was
in rebellion against the divine will. And then in the New Testament you have Jesus
beginning to turn the human will towards God and in the direction of serving God.
Now if you look up Wikipedia, you'll find that there was an awful lot going on
in the world in the 1900s. This is just a tiny summary. In January there was the Second Boar
War in South Africa. There was the Boxer Rebellion in China. In February there's the Second Boar War.
In March there was a coal mine explosion in Virginia and the United States which killed 50.
In April there was a war in Chad which was with the French trying to dominate. In April also there
was anti-Jewish rioting in Budapest and there was the Great Fire in Florida. In May there was
panic when the New York Stock Exchange collapsed. 81 coal miners were killed in Australia.
Also in May also there was an explosion in Utah in the United States killing 200. In May the UK
claimed Tonga from its people in Africa and in May Russia invaded Manchuria. That's a lot going on.
In June the Imperial German Army expanded. There was a terrible fire in New Jersey in which 300
odd people were killed. In July King Uberto the 1st of Italy was assassinated.
The guy is already dead. In September, which we're in September now,
there was a hurricane in the United States that killed 8,000 people. There was a war between
the USA and the Philippines. Also the USA president was assassinated and Roosevelt took over.
In November the British forces in South Africa used a scorched earth policy to do the most
dreadful things. So that will just give you a feeling as to what the Lord is talking about,
the perverted world and countries stealing other countries and terrible disasters and everything
happening. So September the 10th. This morning Louisa said, "I found myself outside of myself
and I saw the many evils and most enormous sins that were being committed also against the church
and the Holy Father." Then as I returned inside of myself, I think it's around this time that they
made the Pope, the prisoner of the Vatican as well. Then as I returned inside of myself,
my adorable Jesus came and he told me, "What do you say about the world?" Not knowing what this
question was driving at. Impressed as I was by the things I had seen, I said, "Blessed Lord,
who can tell the perversity, the hardness and the ugliness of the world?" I've no words to say
how bad it is. And then he, taking the occasion from my very words, said, "You've seen how perverted
it is. You yourself said it. There is no way to make it surrender to the divine will understood."
So after I have almost taken bread away from it, oh dear, that means there's going to be famines
and there were many famines in the 20th century in different parts of the world.
It remains in its stubbornness. Now there's a text that I just come to my head at this moment
and it's in Amos. Oh, what chapter is it? Where Amos says, "The Lord says, 'I left your teeth clean
in all your towns.'" That's a famine. "And you never came back to me. I did this. I did that.
I did the other. You never came back to me." And then finally it says, "Israel, prepare to meet
your God." That means in judgment. Okay? And this is what you're reading here.
That even with the famines, they still wouldn't do it. They stay, not only did they stay in their
stubbornness, but it was even worse. For now it goes on procuring by thefts. That's the stealing
of different countries and that's why I wanted to read that list for you and robberies doing harm
to one's neighbor. Therefore it is necessary that I touch its flesh. Now I want to give you Job chapter
two verses one to seven because in chapter one there was a dialogue between Satan and God about
Job and God bolstered that Job was his best servant down there. And Satan said, "Well, of course
you've given him everything." You know, he's totally successful. He's a large family. He's a happy man
and blah, blah, blah. And he said, "Take them away and he'll curse you." And we know that when the
disasters happened, Job said God has given God has taken away. Blessed be the Lord. So then there
was a second meeting between Satan and God and Satan. God said, "I told you, he's my best servant."
And Satan said, "Ah, but if you touch his flesh, it will be different." He said, "The sons and
daughters were not him. The cattle were not him. The fields were not him. That's all outside of him.
Touch his own flesh and you'll see for yourself." And Shakespeare picked that up in one of his plays
as well, talking about the pound of flesh. And so Jesus says here to Louisa that since
all the disasters outside of them have not touched them, do you see the connection with Job?
Now he said, "I'll have to touch their flesh." In other words, they have to feel it themselves
before they will even know I'm trying to talk to them. Otherwise he said, "It will become even
more perverted." So touching the flesh now means disasters that will happen that they will suffer
from. Who can say how speechless I remained with these words of Jesus, Louisa said, "It seems to me
that I myself have been the occasion of making him even more indignant against the world. Instead of
excusing it, I painted it black." I did as much as I could to excuse it afterwards. She said,
"But he didn't pay attention to me." In other words, she spoke the truth and he accepted it.
The evil was already done. We would say the harm was already done because it wasn't evil. She just
simply told him how it was. "Allor, forgive me for this lack of charity," she said, "Have mercy
on us all." So September the 12th, 1900, the so-called sin of Louisa and plots of revolution
against the church. It continues almost in the same way. She said, "This morning on coming,
he poured his bitterness, and I was left in so much suffering that I began to pray the Lord to give me
the strength to relieve me a little bit." Oh, dear. Now the victim's soul is not supposed to ask
to be relieved herself. She's supposed to be relieving the Lord. Okay. But she said, "I couldn't
endure it any longer. I mean, I'm not criticizing her. I'm just pointing it out." In the meantime,
a light came into my mind that is infused knowledge, that I was committing sin in doing this. Okay.
In other words, she was sinning against her role as victim's soul. Besides, what would blessed Jesus
say? "While on other occasions I prayed him to pour this time when he had poured, without waiting
to be asked, I was looking for relief. It seemed to me I am becoming worse, and my badness reaches
such a point that even before him I do not abstain from committing defects and sins."
So not knowing what to do to repair the damage. Okay. "I resolved in my interior that for this time
to make a greater sacrifice and give myself a penance so that my nature would not dare to ask for
relief again. I should renounce the coming of the Lord." Oh. So she makes an offering she can't
actually give because she can't live without it. And he accepts her intention. You see, he knows
she can't live without him because she's living this abnormal life that he has got to sustain
miraculously. But what we have to look at is that on her part, this is a totally heroic act.
Okay. And once she makes this totally heroic act, he accepts it just the intention. You desire
it. I'll do it. Okay. So, and if Jesus came, I would say, "Oh, do not come, love, have compassion
on me and do not relieve me." So I did. And I spent several hours in intense suffering and without
Jesus, how bitter it was for me. But Jesus having compassion for me without asking, my asking for
him, he came. You see, God is love. And immediately I said to him, "Have patience, do not come.
I don't want to relief." And he said, "My daughter, I am content with your sacrifice,
but you do need a refreshment." In other words, he knows that the suffering she's going through
could actually kill her. And he doesn't want that. She's his chosen soul. Otherwise, you faint.
And Louisa said, "No Lord, but I don't want the relief." But drawing near to my mount,
almost by force, he poured a few drops of a sweet milk from his mouth, which mitigated my suffering.
Who can say the confusion and the blushing I felt before him? I expected her approach.
But Jesus showed himself more affable and sweeter as if he had not perceived my fault.
On seeing this, I said, "My adorable Jesus, once you have poured your bitterness into me and I suffer,
don't you have to spare the world? Don't you like? I'm a victim thought."
And he said, "My daughter, do you think I have poured everything into you? Now, go back again
and see this and you'll see that she said, wait a minute now, he poured a few drops."
That's the bit you need to notice. And this sweet milk usually has a great spiritual fortitude
in it, enabling a person to survive. And he said, "Do you think I have poured everything?" He only
gave her a few drops. Besides, how could you face all the chastisement that I will pour? Oh, boys.
How could you? That means one individual face all the chastisement that I, that is the Lord,
will pour over the world. You yourself have seen that you could not endure even the little that
I gave you. In other words, the world is in a much more terrible state than Louisa perceives.
And had I not come to help you, he said, you would have ended. In other words, you have died.
And he doesn't want your dead. That's one of the things that Louisa can't understand. Jesus
doesn't want your dead. The priest doesn't want your dead. Nobody wants her dead because she has
this big job to do. Okay. Now, what would happen if I poured everything into you? My dear, I gave
you my word. I will content you in part. Now, I love my dear bit. In other words, he is approaching
her very lovingly because in order to make reparation for looking for relief, she offered them the
one thing she absolutely couldn't do. And so she has to realize there's only one redeemer.
And our participation is the drop of water that the priest puts into the chalice that makes
the Eucharist. That's all we're capable of because we're only tiny. And you see in higher volumes,
Louisa is told, she's only a nashum. You know, I mean, there's only a certain amount that you can do.
But we do know that the part that he does allow to her is usually one third. And you'll find that
there's one or two exceptions to this. So after this, Jesus transported me outside of myself into
the midst of the people. So that's your Amos 3 7 thing again. And I continued to see so many evils,
especially the plots of revolution against the church within society. So that's your atheistic
communism, Marxism, Freemasonry, and so on. And the infiltration of the clergy by communism.
That's the attack against the church. Because that attack against the church,
we're still reaping the very bitter fruits from that, that we've had literal professional atheists in
the job of bishop and cardinal. I just hope to goodness they never got to the top. I felt my soul
being tortured, Louisa. Oh, yeah, sorry. Especially I saw the plots of revolution against the church
and within society. And the plots to kill the Holy Father, the Holy Father's Leo XIII and priests.
I felt my soul being tortured at the sight of these things. And I thought to myself,
if and may it never be that they come to carry out these things, what would happen? How many
evils will come? And all afflicted, I look at Jesus, he told me, and what about that revolt
that happened here? What do you say about it? And Louisa said, which revolt? Nothing has happened
in my town. He's got to get her to think much wider than my town. She's not even thinking the
whole of Italy, you know. And he said, don't you remember the revolt of the revolt of Andrea?
And she said, Oh, yes. Well, then it seems nothing, but it is so. That was the whole occasion and an
incitement for other towns to revolt and to shed blood and giving a front to consecrated people
and my temples, 1 Corinthians 3 16, my temples are people who have the Lord dwelling in them.
And since everyone wants to show how much better he is in provoking evil, they will compete to see
how much harm they can do. And Louisa said, Our Lord give peace to the church and don't allow so
many troubles. And in saying that she's giving an emotional response, not realizing, because it's
only volume four, that this revolt of the human will against the divine will has got to stop
if the human race is to come back and be able to enter the kingdom of God. So as I wanted to say
more, he disappeared, leaving me all afflicted and concerned. So September the 14th 1900,
Jesus pours his bitterness in order to placate his justice. And we have the heroism of true virtue.
This morning, my adorable Jesus was not coming. Then after much waiting, he made himself seen
within my interior, of course, because the kingdom of God is within you. And that's Luke 17 21.
"Using my heart as a support and surrounding it with his arms." Now he's within her and he's
using her heart as a support. That's what he means by my temples in the last paragraph we've just read
and consecrated our sacred people. And he surrounded my heart with his arms while leaning his most
sacred head upon it, all afflicted serious in such a way as to impose silence and giving his back
to the world. Now that is frightening. If you go to Romans chapter one, three times in Romans one
were told the Lord abandoned them to their filthy practices, the Lord abandoned them to their evil
ways and so on and so on, three times. When the Lord gives his back to us, that's real disaster.
So after remaining a little while in mute silence, because at the appearance at which he showed himself
would not make one dare to say a word. Now for Louisa not to dare to say a word, things are bad
because don't forget she's Italian and it's very difficult to stop the Italians from talking.
He stirred himself from that position and he said to me, "I had resolved not to pour, but things
have reached such a point that if I did not pour, such operars would break out as to start a revolution
and cause bloody slaughter." So Louisa said, "Yes, Lord, pour. This is my only desire that you give
vent to your wrath upon me." You see, there's the victim soul at their best. They stand between the
justice of God and the sinfulness of the people. So they stand in the breach, which is Psalm 106.
"You vent your wrath upon me and spare the creatures." So he poured a little bit.
So I want to give you John 11, 40 to 45 as well. It was better for one man to die for the whole people.
Now you know why she can only take a little bit. We're only one tiny little piece of dust.
Then afterwards, as if he had relieved himself, he said, "My daughter, I allowed myself to be brought
to the slaughter like a lamb." That is Isaiah 53 7. "And I remain silent before those who sacrificed
me." The same will happen for those few good people of these times. Now, you're talking, yeah, however,
this is the heroism of true virtue. Now you're talking about the 20th century produced more
martyrs for Christ than the 19th centuries added together before it. So you're talking about the
martyrs of Russia and China and Japan and Europe and all the other places. Again, he added, "I poured,
but even though I did, do you want me to pour a little bit more so that I can relieve myself more?"
And Louisa said, "My Lord, don't even ask me. I'm at your disposal." So here you've got a demonstration
of what total surrender is. You can do with me whatever you want. So he poured again and he
disappeared, leaving me in suffering but content, thinking that I had relieved the pains of my
beloved Jesus. So she feels that she has done something for him and also for the world.
So September the 16th, you have the turmoil in Andrea in Italy. Continuing to come, my
beloved Jesus shared with me various pains of his passion and then he transported me outside of
myself. Showing me the neighboring towns, in particular it seemed to me it was Andrea.
And if the Lord does not make use of his omnipotence for their chastisement,
the turmoil will get serious. More so since it seemed that there was the incitement of some
priests. Now this is the problem. No wonder Jesus is suffering. That priests get involved in stuff
that they should stay out of completely. It's not their business. They should be looking after
the church, not the world. Then after I visited various churches together with blessed Jesus,
doing acts of reparation and adoration for the many prophonations committed in the churches.
Isn't that incredible? Last year, 1900. Jesus told me, "My daughter, let me pour a little bit
for the bitterness is such that I cannot swallow it alone and my heart cannot bear it."
So he poured and he disappeared, returning other times without telling me anything else.
So this time now she's making reparation for Italy and for what's going on in the church as well.
So let's come to September the 18th, 1900. This is about love.
He keeps on coming back to this over and over and over again because love is one of the biggest
themes in the 36 volumes. In fact, the 36 volumes has two themes, love and divine love, divine love,
divine will, same person. So if we don't conquer love, we don't conquer anything.
This morning my adorable Jesus transported me outside of myself and showed me the many evils
committed against love towards one's neighbor. Okay, now love is one Corinthians 13 verses 1 to 13.
One Corinthians 14 verse 1, Ephesians 3, 16 to 21. You have John 13, 34 to 35. You've got John
15, 9. You've got Matthew 22. And I can't remember the verse at this moment that the whole scripture
depends on the two laws of loving God and loving your neighbor. Now we keep on coming back to this
all the time because if we don't get this, as I say, we get nothing.
This morning my adorable Jesus transported me outside of myself and showed me the many evils
committed against love towards one's neighbor. How much sorrow they caused to our most patient
Jesus. It seemed that he himself was receiving them, of course, because he has taken the whole
of humanity into himself. And then he is the church. Then all afflicted, he told me,
my daughter, one who harms his neighbor, harms himself. Now I want to give you also Matthew 25,
the judgment scene then, where the people who land themselves in hell did not look after their
neighbors. And by killing his neighbor, he kills his own soul. And since charity predisposes the soul
for all virtues, because charity is missing, the soul is predisposed to commit all vices. Ouch.
That's that's one that you just need to read over and over and over again.
After this we withdrew, Louisa said, and since for several days I had been suffering from an
intense pain in my ribs, at my ribs, I felt exhausted. And so comforting me, blessed Jesus,
told me, my beloved, you'd like to come, wouldn't you? That means to die. So he was testing her again.
And Louisa said, heaven's willing, my Lord, that this pain be the cause of my coming to you.
How grateful I would be, how dearly I would hold to it. That's your two Corinthians five
verses one to 10. How grateful I would be, how dearly I would hold it as one of my faithful
friends. But I think you want to test me like the other times. And by exciting me with your
invitations, since I would then remain disillusioned, you would come to make my martyrdom even more
cruel and harrowing. Oh, please, she said, have compassion on me, and do not leave me on the
earth any longer. Absorbed this miserable world into yourself, for I have the right to this,
since it is from you that I came. How clever she is. Since I came from you, I have the right to go back
to you. All moved in hearing me, beloved Jesus told me, my daughter, do not fear, for your day
in which you will be absorbed in me will surely come. Oh, but not for many, many years yet.
No, however, that your continuous violence to come to me at Matthew 11 12, I think it is
the kingdom of God suffers violence and the valiant take it by forth. That your continuous
violence to come to me, especially after my invitations, do great good to you and make you live in the
atmosphere of the air. That means in an entirely spiritual atmosphere, without a shadow of human
weight. And what he's doing, it seems cruel. But what he's doing is he's actually enabling her
to become completely spiritualized, and he does succeed in doing it. So there's literally nothing
holding her to the earth. One of the saddest things for us to witness is somebody dying,
and they're still clinging to the earth. They don't want to die. They don't want to leave the
earth because they've got money or they've got power or they've got whatever. 3D said.
This does you much good, he said, because you live in an atmosphere all divine without a shadow
of human weight, so much so that you are like those flowers who have not even got their roots
upon the earth. We've learned, it's amazing that he says this in 1900, because it's only
towards the latter end of the 20th century that we discovered how you could actually grow plants
in the air. They did experiments on that so that they'd learn how to grow plants in space, for example.
By living in this way suspended in the air, you come to impress heaven and earth, and in looking
at heaven you are impressed by it alone, and you nourish yourself with all that is celestial.
And looking at the earth you feel sorrow for it, compassion, and you help it as much as you can,
that is with your intercession, with your prayers, with your sufferings. However,
at the comparison between the fragrance of heaven, with the fragrance of heaven, you immediately
perceive the stench that emanates on the earth. Of course, the closer you get to heaven, the more
horrific what's going on in earth looks. And he said, you abhor it. Could I perhaps place you
in a position more dear to me and to heaven and more beneficial for you and for the world? In other
words, in enticing her in this way, enticing her to rise higher. Jesus is in fact helping her
and helping her to help. Louisa said, yet my Lord, you should have compassion for me
by not prolonging my residence down here, and for so many reasons that I have, especially then
for the sad times that are preparing. Who would have the heart to see such a bloody slaughter?
And yet she will, she will live through two world wars. And also, for your continuous
privations that cost me more than death. As I was saying this, she said, I saw a multitude
of angels around our Lord saying, our Lord and God, do not let yourself be importuned and
no longer make her content. We are anxiously waiting for her. Isn't that fantastic?
Wounded by her voice, we have come here to listen to her, and we are impatient to take her with us.
And you, O chosen one, that's Louisa, come to cheer us in our celestial dwelling. Isn't that
absolutely amazing? So not only did Jesus test her, but now she's getting more problems with
the angels saying, we can't wait. Blessed Jesus moved, seemed to want to condescend, and then he
disappeared. As I found myself inside of myself, I felt my pain increased so much so that I was
in continuous spasm, but I couldn't understand myself for the contentment. And that's because
she's had such closeness to heaven. And the Lord has shown her how closely heaven is waiting for her.
So September the 19th is about the obedience to ask Jesus for relief for her pains. Now she's
had a problem by asking for relief before, but obedience is asking her now. As the spasm of pain
doubled more and more, I would have wanted to hide it so that no one would notice it. I would
have wanted to keep it secret without opening up to the confessor about the things I've said above.
But the spasm was so strong that it was impossible for me to do it. And the confessor making use of
his usual weapon of obedience commanded me to manifest everything to him. Then after I manifested
everything to him, he told me that out of obedience, now this is completely different, isn't it?
That out of obedience, I was to pray the Lord to free me. Otherwise, I would be committing sin.
That's the sin of disobedience, okay? What a kind of obedience she said. She, that is obedience,
is always the one to come across my designs. Of course, that's the whole thing that Jesus has
taught us about obedience, that the purpose of obedience is to kill the human will.
That's the purpose of obedience is to kill the human will and therefore allow the divine will to
take over. And therefore, the the obedience is that are given to Louisa are the exact opposite
of what she actually wants. So she said, unwillingly, I accepted this new obedience, but in spite of
this, I did not have the heart to pray the Lord to free me of a friend so dear, that is the suffering
that makes all the difference to relieving him and saving her neighbor. More so since I was hoping
to go out with the exile of this life. So she has that as a secondary motive. "Blessed Jesus
tolerated me, and on coming he said to me, 'You suffer very much, do you want me to free you?'
And I, forgetting for a moment about the obedience, said, 'No Lord, no, no, don't free me, I want to
come.' You see, it's her our motive that she wants to die, to be with the Lord, is what's making
her forget the other obedience. Besides, she said, 'You know that I don't know how to love you, I am
cold, I don't do great things for you, at least I offer you this suffering to satisfy for what I'm
unable to do to love you.' And he said, 'And I, my daughter, will infuse so much love and so much
grace.' And you know from volume two that Grace is an outpouring of himself. He said, 'I am Grace.'
So God is love and God is Grace. I will infuse so much love and so much grace in you. In other words,
God will pour himself out so completely on you that no one will be able to love me and desire me as
you do. Now, I want you to underline that in green, white and gold. And in later volumes,
you'll find that Jesus takes her to heaven and he boasts before all the heavenly dwellers,
that nobody loves him like Louisa. He said, 'Aren't you happy?' Yes, she said, 'But I want to come.'
Jesus disappeared because it's not the time. And I returned inside of myself and I remembered about
the obedience. And I had to accuse myself before the confessor who commanded me that he absolutely
did not want me to go. So here's the obedience not to die. So the poor girl and that the Lord
should free me. What pain I felt in receiving this obedience, it really seems that she obedience
wants to touch the extremes of my patience. The poor girl, she's really suffering. So September
the 20th, a 1900, signs of the cross to heal her. I continue to suffer. Even more, I felt a resentment
in my interior more than ever, for I was being forbidden to die. Now, the resentment is this
negative feeling and it's not sinned if you don't give into it. So it might help, since we're not
at the level that Louisa is at, that you look at the book of Sirek or Ecclesiasticus and I think
it's chapter 37 and it should be at the very beginning of it. If I have it right or else it's the
beginning of chapter 38. I think it's 37 and it says that resentment is a foul thing and it's found
with sinners. And this is why, you know, when Louisa is tempted to have these negative reactions,
that Jesus will always say to her, "Don't put your will into it. Don't put your will into it."
And then you'll be able to deal with it. So, "Uncoming my adorable Jesus reproached me for my delay
in obeying." Oh, because why she's supposed to imitate him in everything and it was her delay
in obeying. Now, while up to that moment, he had seemed to tolerate me. In the meantime,
I saw the confessor and turning to him, Jesus took his hand and said, "When you come, that is to
visit Louisa, sign her in the place of the pain, for I will make her obey." So the priest is now
told by the Lord that she must receive the sign of the cross in the place where she is suffering.
So then she said, "As I remained alone, I felt the pain more intensely." Then the confessor came
and finding me in suffering, he too reproached me, for I was not obeying. And I told him what I had
seen and what our Lord had said to the confessor. On hearing me, he signed the place where I was
suffering and in two minutes I was able to breathe and move. Now, I want you to notice there that is
the priest obeys the Lord, even though he got the message through Louisa. He doesn't appear to
have got the message directly, but that's a sign of real humility on the part of the priest,
that he will accept a message indirectly from the Lord. So in two minutes, you said, I was able to
breathe and move, while before I couldn't do it without feeling atrocious spasms. It seems to me
that obedience and those signs of the cross, now it's really the obedience of the priest and his
humility, have bound my pain in such a way that I can no longer suffer. And here is how I have
remained disillusioned in my designs. In other words, nothing will allow her to die. In fact,
this lady obedience has taken so much power over me. She lets me do nothing of what I want,
because the whole idea is that the human will must surrender to the divine. And you see, all of this
has got to happen in the early volumes, so that the miracle of living in the divine will
happens to her. That's why obedience has got to be so cruel, as she says. And even in the suffering
itself, the obedience wants to be Lord, and I have to remain entirely and completely under her empire,
that means total surrender. Okay, so I keep telling people that our motto has to be not my will,
but thine be done. I'm writing this down. Not my will, but thine be done. And we've got to say
that a million times a day, and certainly as often as somebody crosses your will. So I'm going to leave
it there for the moment.